[Music]
are we in the middle of a potential
third wade for cobit good evening to you
thank you for joining us i'm brian
loftis
and i'm denise valdez so right now state
health leaders are warning of so-called
covet fatigue the i-team's david charns
has a look at some new data
showing a concerning rise in cases and
especially hospitalizations
david yeah denise this is just fresh new
data we're going to start with the
number of coveted cases here in clark
county you see 421 per 100 thousand
that's considered high
it's important to note that the data for
these cases is a couple days behind so
none of these numbers include any
possible transmission from this
weekend's political rallies
or early voting take a look at this
graph though this gives us a good idea
of where we are in terms of cases you
see that peak there in
april then we have another one there in
august of course we had that first and
second wave it looks like though a
third peak is coming there and experts
say
it's a little too soon to say for sure
but this is a little concerning that
those numbers are going up
they say though we're seeing covid
fatigue set in as more of us become
comfortable seeing our friends our
families again some of us though aren't
wearing our masks
there could be a group of people
carpooling and you had four infections
as a result of a carpool
or um a certain get-together be it for
more informal where people
um felt the level of comfort not to mask
or
um did not honor social distancing so i
again just
encourage people to knock it fatigue
she adds that really is important as we
head into halloween
thanksgiving christmas now just about
two months away not putting our guards
down just yet
this is another graph just released it's
a 14-day average of deaths again we see
that big
rise there in july and august and we're
seeing a slow decline
this is good news because it's likely
because we're seeing fewer
older people get infected with coping
more younger people
still not great but younger people of
course better able to fight off the
disease and then one more to show you
here if i can get this
right and erase this here we go so this
is the look at hospitalizations you see
it's pretty flat
we are seeing a little bit of an
increase there that is concerning
because
it's actually a new high since early
september we're about 500 people now
and again a new high in the past couple
of weeks so we'll stay on top of this
for you
i'm david charns 8 news now all right on
the heels of that report david another